des amphithéâtres connecter des tableaux
tactiles et des cours par
visioconférence comme si vous y étiez
voici quelques innovations qui
pourraient se retrouver demain dans les
universités françaises des nouveautés
présentées à thierry mandon secrétaire
d'état à l'enseignement supérieur et à
la recherche au sein du bâtiment
challenger de bouygues construction à
guyancourt comme ce tableau digital est
tactile voilà l'idée c'est effectivement
de ça se présente comme un tableau blanc
numérique cette fois c'est hier que on
va pouvoir écrire avec le stylo on va
pouvoir est vide effectivement avoir une
surface d'écriture assez classique sur
laquelle on va également pouvoir
interagir avec les doigts donc on va
pouvoir zoomer dézoomer et lorsqu'on m'a
déçu mais on va également s'apercevoir
qu'on appela profité d'avoir plusieurs
pages
cette société travaille en partenariat
avec bouygues construction sur le thème
du campus connecter une problématique
cher aux secrétaires d'état il avait
annoncé en avril dernier un plan de 50
mesures destinées à moderniser les
facultés
premièrement on doit révolutionner la
façon d'apprendre la pédagogie ça passe
par le numérique est ici dans le campus
connectés dans le savoir-faire du campus
connectés de bouygues il ya cette
technologie là qui sont domestiqués
deuxièmement nous avons en termes de
stratégie immobilière de faire des
locaux à la fois confortables
accueillant hospitalier une nouvelle
façon d'apprendre et en même temps
respectueux de l'environnement aussi un
autre défi et je trouvais qu'il ya pas
de mise visite plus approprié que celle
ci pour voir des expériences concrètes
de réussite de la transformation
numérique de la pédagogie et de la
transformation durable de l'immobilier
avec ses projets de campus connectés
l'entreprise bouygues s'est rapidement
positionnée pour concevoir des espaces
d'éducation adapter le monde de
l'université de l'enseignement supérieur
de la recherche est en pleine ébullition
en france comme partout dans le monde
car les nouvelles technologies arrivent
celle du numérique et ces technologies
vont bouleverser la vision que l'on a de
l'enseignement supérieur donc il est
important pour nous qui sommes des
intégrateurs de solutions de montrer
comment on peut aborder ces universités
par l' usage
les mesures annoncées par thierry mandon
sont très liés à l'innovation comme le
développement de la visioconférence et
la généraliser
du numérique elles rentreront en
application à partir de la rentrée 2016
et en 2017